why
so in an event to stay current with the
events in Marvel Comics we're going to
begin discussing the story of original
sin and the reason for this is because
again we want to stay current we want to
maintain this element of keeping up with
the current events in Marvel Comics so
that we can always know what's going on
but also going back and touching on some
previous events like the Infinity
Gauntlet and the siege Dark Reign in the
House of M so that we can understand how
some of these events unfolded we can
understand how it is that the superhero
community has been led to the place that
it is now for the most part issue number
zero of the original sin storyline
doesn't do too much for us with the
exception of giving us an understanding
of the background of the watcher of uatu
the watcher and so we're going to skip
ahead a little bit then what we see here
is that Sam Alexander the current Nova
is traveling to the moon to the Watchers
watchtower because Sam Alexander is
faced with a quandary of sorts the
question Sam Alexander has is that if we
walk to the watcher watches if he simply
just observes things any chronicles
these things then the question is why
why does he do this there has to be some
kind of basis behind it there has to be
some kind of reason as for why he does
this then this of course was the
question that he had asked of Captain
America and Iron Man and Captain America
it simply replied that it was a question
no one ever thought to ask before nobody
ever really asked why The Watcher
watches they'd simply accept the fact
that he does and so what we see is that
Sam Alexander arrives at the Watchers
lair and meets with the watcher but
because the watcher doesn't really talk
Sam Alexander is a little unsure how to
conduct himself under these scenarios
but what he does is he maintains the
normal etiquette for appearing at an
individual's house then he brings the
watcher a gift he tells the watcher that
he's not really able to buy any kind of
wine or anything which for the most part
is customary when visiting somebody but
he says that in return he is he's
brought a piece of the territory whereby
the Avengers were able to stop the x-men
or the Avengers and the x-men rather
we're able to stop the Phoenix v and so
this is kind of a souvenir it's really
the best thing that Sam Alexander
knows how to do in terms of presenting a
gift to watch you the watcher from here
we see the watcher go back into his lair
and Sam Alexander is a little tentative
if he's not really sure what this means
but he assumes that what the watcher
means here is that he's intending to
invite him in and so Sam Alexander
begins to follow him the Sam Alexander
looks around and realizes that there's
really no no paraphernalia with regards
to family mementos or any kind of
pictures of friends or anything like
that it's basically just this vast
technological hive and it seems a little
a little barren it seems a little
depersonalized
in the sense that there's really nothing
here to make the watcher up here
anything more than some kind of vague
unknown individual - Sam Alexander and
so what we see is that almost
immediately when Sam Alexander begins to
travel further into the Watchers lair
that his helmet goes off now if you
recall our discussion about Richard
Rider as Nova we talked about how
Richard riders helmet will inform him
when there's some kind of danger it
would give him a warning which you would
be able to interpret and of course a
counter that danger accordingly and so
think of this as a kind of spider sense
for Nova what we see going on is that
again as Bella continues to enter or
continues to travel further into the
lair of The Watcher he sees these
various forms of The Watcher and for the
most part at this point in time we don't
really know what these are all we know
is that these are just different forms
of The Watcher perhaps it's the watcher
from different realities perhaps it's
all the possibilities or all the
possible places the watcher could have
been but for the most part we're just
kind of left to our imagination in terms
of what these Watchers could be but what
we see Sam Alexander going through here
what we see I'm understanding is this
idea that his helmet gives him
information that his helmet is warning
him but at the same time he doesn't seem
like there's a doesn't see what there's
a reason for him to be concerned now
what we see is again as SF Alexander
continues through the lair of The
Watcher he realizes that amid his his
investigation of all these ghost
versions of The Watcher as he calls it
that he's lost the lost track of the
real watcher and so he begins to go on
this sort of hunt he begins to look
around for the watcher himself
eventually he comes across what he
thinks may be some kind of a of an
armory of sorts when he opens the door
he realizes that's exactly what it is
what we see in this armory is a vast
collection of various weapons some of
which we've seen before and some of
which we haven't and among these weapons
is the ultimate nullifier now this is a
very big deal because again we discuss
on several occasions what the ultimate
nullifier is and the ultimate nullifier
is exactly what it sounds like it
nullifies it eradicated things from
existence and this ultimate nullifier
will become important later on when we
get into the mindless ones and we see
Nick Fury and various other superheroes
responding to a crisis with the mindless
ones in in New York City what we see
here is that Sam Alexander is surprised
to see that the ultimate nullifier
simply just there he understands the
effect of the no ultimate nullifier
despite the fact that he's never
actually seen it used in person but he
knows that this is a very dangerous
thing in addition he speculates here
that The Watcher was by virtue of
chronicling various events also
collecting things he was also collecting
different artifacts collecting different
weapons and things like that and maybe
it was for safekeeping we're not really
sure what what the Watchers intention
was here but what we see is that again
Sam Alexander's helmet begins to go
crazy it begins to alert him that
something very significant is taking
place with regards to to his immediate
surroundings indicating that there is a
vast amount of danger that could be
approaching him what we also see here is
that Sam Alexander begins to travel
around he begins and to look around in
search of The Watcher and again
encounters more of these ghost versions
of The Watcher and ultimately what we
see is that Sam Alexander is able to
find The Watcher he's able to locate the
actual watcher of this reality and he
simply asks them a female giant and
again the watch remains silent here the
watcher doesn't answer what we see is
that Sam Alexander is looking at the
watcher in such a way to where he
understands why it is that his helmet
has been gone awry the helmets gone awry
because of something called the
multiversal friction engine and this is
what is used to power the Watchers
watchtower and the multiversal friction
engine as I understand it is energy that
is the the result of all the multiverses
coming into contact with one another or
bumping up against one another but more
or less it's what's left over as the
multiverses exist
and so this if I understand it correctly
is what feeds the the power source of
the watchers watchtower in addition we
see that Sam Alexander is looking at the
watcher and realizes that he seems to be
waiting for something he seems to be
looking for something and that he
doesn't really know what it is he
doesn't really know what it is that The
Watcher is hunting for but then we see
that as Sam Alexander gets closer to the
watcher that various screens begin to
light up and this is when we get the
backstory of who watching the Watchers
race and what we learn here is that who
watch the watcher is a member of one of
the oldest races in the history of the
universe and that these races at that
time or this race at that time existed
to both chronicle and possibly to
interact but for the most part they were
a very proud race and so what we see is
that one of the individuals a person
named mmm new I believe is the is not
necessarily the leader of the Watchers
but is one of the more respected members
of the Watchers and what we see is that
Ecore or Ike or I'm not exactly how to
pronounce it who's the father of a wat -
is in a debate with M nu and E Corps
says that it's their job it's their goal
as a more advanced race to reach out to
other races to help those races that are
less advanced to be guided properly to
take the right steps towards the
direction of becoming a more advanced
race but to also be a better contributor
to the universe as a whole we see that M
nu is avidly against this M nu says that
it's not their place to involve
themselves in the goings-on of races
which are lower than them of races which
are are irrelevant to them we then see
that that lots of The Watcher speaks up
watch of The Watcher says that because
the Watchers have such vast strength
that if they don't use it to help other
people if they don't use it to help
other races advance themselves then all
their volunteers strength is simply just
a sham so what we see is that is that M
nu is in effect over he's al voted he's
overruled by the council and I cores I
guess I horse ideology stand that the
watchers are going to involve themselves
and helping to assist other races and
the first race that they choose as a
race called the
Prostate proselyte khun's i guess is how
you pronounce it i'm not sure why that
name had to be chosen but what we see is
that the watchers appear to this race
bringing them the gift of nuclear energy
and we too we see the watchers telling
the prosecution's that the nuclear
energy will give them the opportunity to
advance themselves technologically and
it will move them light years ahead of
where they currently are and so what we
see is that over the course of about a
decade or so this race is able to
advance themselves they're able to
eliminate hunger and disease and they're
able to usher in a new era of what
appears to be peace and so due to the
success of this we see that the Watchers
begin to expand their reach out further
into the universe they begin to move
forward and move in the direction of
touching other races but ultimately what
we see is that the the efforts of the
Watchers bring them back to to the
prostatitis planet and when they arrive
they realize that what had happened is
that given the nuclear energy that had
been gift from the watchers that the
proselyte khun's had in effect destroyed
themselves they had devolved into a
state of nuclear warfare and annihilated
their entire race and so from here we
see that I Corps is a very distraught by
this he is absolutely devastated by this
and so as a result he comes to this
realization that M nu was why's that M
nu was smart and making the decision
that The Watcher should simply just
Chronicle events but they should never
interact we see that we ought to try to
plead with his father and tell him that
this is not the case that this was
simply just one example but that other
races still may chair or so may flourish
they may still grow and expand and not
succumb to the same kind of a fate that
was left to the pro so Lincoln's but we
see that his father won't hear it and
that his father has taken the stance
that the Watchers should not involve
themselves and their goings on of
anybody else and so from here we
transitioned back to Sam Alexander and
what we see is that Sam Alexander begins
to maybe express some kind of remorse
for what it was that had happened to
watch whose father he says that he
doesn't really know what to say here he
says that he tries to start by saying
that he's sorry but it just doesn't
really seem to de comprehend it it
doesn't really seem to
you I guess maybe quell the kind of
grief that walked to the watcher has
knowing that his race had effectively
contributed to another race completely
wiping itself out due to a gift that was
given in addition he has to watch her
what it is that he watches how much of
the observable universe is it that the
The Watcher looks at and what we see is
that watch of the watcher reveals to Sam
Alexander the fact that he watches
everything and when we say everything we
mean absolutely everything not just this
reality but all realities in addition
the idea here is that the watcher is
looking for something and what the
watcher is looking for is given to us by
Sam Alexander when Sam Alexander comes
to the realization that all these
various images all are from different
realities when he sees that there is an
african-american version of Captain
America which may very well be a future
version of the Falcon which indicates to
us that this may not be all realities
that it may simply just be this one
reality but then we see that as Sam
Alexander's helmet begins to to warn him
that the constant motion the influx of
energy from the the multiversal engine
would ultimately result in his
destruction we see that he realizes
there's a set of images there are
there's once one event that seems to
repeat itself every single time and
every single reality and it's always the
same it never changes and this is the
instance whereby his father had given
nuclear energy to the prosthetic uns and
they had destroyed themselves and so we
see that this is what The Watcher is
looking for The Watcher is looking for
one instance whereby this didn't happen
where this race didn't eradicate itself
given the energy of nuclear power that
was given to them by the Watchers and so
this is what The Watcher looks for this
is what he's been hunting for all this
time and all this really does is give us
us understanding that The Watcher has
emotions The Watcher has feelings The
Watcher despite the fact that he doesn't
voice them despite the fact that his for
the most part the facial features or his
expressions don't really change that he
is part of a race that is hungry for
something that he's hungry for a way to
prove that his father was right to prove
that his father wasn't wrong and saying
that the Watchers should relegate
themselves to simply observing and never
interacting in addition we see Sam
Alexander begin to I guess move away
begin to tell the watcher that again he
didn't necessarily want to intrude here
that he didn't want to to play the role
of somebody who didn't need to be there
and so again he pleads with the watcher
one last time and he asked the watcher
if the watcher knows where his father is
because one of the big character aspects
of Sam Alexander is the location of his
father who would simply just vanished
and again this is something that we'll
get into when we do a further
explanation on the character Nova and we
get into the role that Sam Alexander
plays but we see the Sam Alexander says
The Watcher watches everything and so if
the watcher sees everything in this
reality then surely the watcher knows
where his father is he recognizes that
the watcher may not be able to tell him
that The Watcher may not be able to tell
him exactly word as it his father's ad
and so we see Sam Alexander accept the
fact that and effectively effectively
tell the watcher if he can't tell us a
magazine Sam Alexander woods father is
and it's okay it's not a great big huge
problem and so we see that Sam Alexander
begins to move away but then we see the
watcher tell Sam Alexander that his
father is alive and so for Sam Alexander
this is a big deal and Sam Alexander
celebrates this this fact he celebrates
this recognition that his father is very
much alive as like how it begins to come
to a close what we see here is again
this element of The Watcher having
remorse of this element of The Watcher
not being an individual who is devoid of
any kind of emotion whatsoever when the
watcher takes out the trinket that had
been given to him by Sam Alexander the
piece of ground where the x-men of the
Avengers were able to stop the the
Phoenix v and he puts it on a pedestal
as a way to to remind him or maybe as a
way to to keep it as a memento that
somebody out there is concerned about
him this brings an end to original sin
issue number zero and again all this was
designed to do is to give us an
understanding of the watcher to give us
this idea of what the possible impacts
could be if the watcher were killed
which is something that we'll pick up
with with original sin issue number one
with that being said I'm going to go and
bring this video to an end I hope you
guys enjoyed it if you did let me know
and I will catch you guys later peace